>> Dana: THANK YOU, ANDY.
>> THANKS.
>> IF YOU SEE THE LEVEL COMING
DOWN REALLY, REALLY VERY LOW, I
WANT IT TO KEEP GOING DOWN TO A
BASELINE THAT’S SO LOW THAT
THERE IS VIRTUALLY NO THREAT.
IF YOU COMBINE GETTING MOST OF
THE PEOPLE IN THE COUNTRY
VACCINATED WITH GETTING THE
LEVEL OF VIRUS IN THE COMMUNITY
VERY, VERY LOW, THEN I BELIEVE
YOU WILL BE ABLE TO SAY FOR THE
MOST PART WE DON’T NECESSARILY
HAVE TO WEAR MASKS.
>> Dana: DR. FAUCI LAYING OUT
THE CASE FOR CONTINUED MASK
WEARING INTO 2022 AS THE
VACCINATION ROLL-OUT
ACCELERATES IN THE U.S.
WITH THE FIRST REAL WORLD
EVIDENCE OF THE VACCINE’S
IMPACT COMING OUT OF ISRAEL
WILL WE RETURN TO NORMAL SOONER
THAN THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
IS PREDICTING?
JOINING US NOW, DR. MARC SIEGEL.
FOR PEOPLE TO SEE THE PFIZER
EFFICACY DATA IN ISRAEL IS
IMPRESSIVE, 98.9% AS PREVENTIVE
INFECTION AND 78 DOSES
ADMINISTERED THROUGH 800 PEOPLE.
DO WE HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT
WEARING MASKS INTO 2022?
>> WE NEED A SIMPLE MESSAGE
THAT WE CAN ALL GO BY.
HERE IS WHAT IT IS.
DR. FAUCI, WHO I RESPECT A LOT,
IS BEING TOO PESSIMISTIC
PROVIDED WE FOLLOW THE OTHER
PART OF HIS MESSAGE WHICH IS
GET VACCINATED.
WE HAVE LESS THAN 50% -- WE
HAVE A PROBLEM WITH 40 OR 50%
OF AMERICANS NOT SAYING THEY’LL
BE VACCINATED.
I SAY TO THE PEOPLE GET THE
VACCINE AND THEN WE’LL TALK
ABOUT TAKING OFF THE MASKS.
I DON’T THINK IT WILL BE 2022
PROVIDED WE CAN GET THIS
COUNTRY VACCINATED.
THE DATA YOU JUST SHOWED PROVES
IT.
THE PFIZER DATA OUT OF ISRAEL
IS INCREDIBLY IMPRESSIVE AND
NEW DATA LOOKS LIKE IT CUTS
DOWN ON TRANCE MISSABILITY, THE
KEY.
THAT’S WHY I’M TALKING ABOUT
PROTECT EVERYBODY AROUND YOU
ALREADY.
DON’T JUST PROTECT YOURSELF.
YOU WON’T GET HOSPITALIZED.
THE CHANCES ARE YOU WON’T GET
SICK OR GET THE INFECTION.
VERY HIGH PERCENTAGES ON TOP OF
THAT VERY LITTLE CHANCE YOU
WILL TRANSMIT IT TO OTHERS.
YOU WANT TO TAKE THAT MASK OFF?
TAKE THE VACCINE.
>> Bill: THE DECREASE IN CASES
AND DEATHS AND HOSPITALIZATIONS
GOING BACK TO EARLY JANUARY ARE
EXTRAORDINARY.
WE’RE DOWN 77% SINCE THE HIGH
RIGHT AROUND THE FIRST OF THE
YEAR.
AND THEN THERE IS THIS NEWS,
TOO.
TOP COUNTRIES THE COVID VACCINE
DOSES ADMINISTERED.
WE RANK NUMBER FOUR.
ISRAEL ONE, UAE2, UNITED
KINGDOM THREE AND U.S. FOUR.
ARE WE DOING A LOT BETTER JOB
THAN THE MEDIA IS TELLING US?
>> YES, ALL THE POLITICAL BACK
BITING.
ADMINISTRATION DOESN’T WANT TO
GIVE ANY CREDIT TO THE PREVIOUS
ADMINISTRATION.
THEY WANT TO SAY NOTHING WAS
DONE PROPERLY WHEN WE HAD THIS
ENORMOUS ROLL OUT ON A VACCINE
PUT TOGETHER IN NINE MONTHS.
THE STATES ARE FIGHTING EACH
OTHER.
NEW YORK STATE HAD TO PUT AN
EXTRA LAYER OF SURVEILLANCE ON
THE VACCINE.
NOW WE’RE FINALLY FINDING
INFORMATION OUT THAT WILL
REALLY HELP, BILL.
WE’RE FINDING OUT THE PFIZER
VACCINE CAN BE STORED IN A
REGULAR FREEZER.
THAT WILL MEAN A BIGGER
ROLL-OUT.
GETTING MORE PEOPLE ON THE
GROUND TO ADMINISTER THESE
VACCINES.
MORE VACCINES CENTERS.
WE’RE UP TO 2 MILLION DOSES A
DAY NOW.
WE WERE UP TO 1 MILLION AT THE
TIME OF THE CHANGING OF THE
GUARD.
I THINK WE’RE DOING A GOOD JOB
WITH VACCINE.
A LOT OF THINGS ARE MAKING US
MOVE IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
WE AREN’T GATHERING AS MUCH.
WEARING MASKS, STARTING TO GET
VACCINATED.
THE KEY THING IS WE ALSO HAVE A
LOT OF IMMUNITY BUILT UP IN THE
COUNTRY.
PROBABLY -- THIS IS NOT
PROVABLE, IT IS JUST -- THERE
HAS BEEN A LOT MORE CASES OF
COVID-19 OUT THERE THAN WE KNOW
ABOUT.
PEOPLE THAT HAD SYMPTOMS THAT
DIDN’T GET TESTED.
PEOPLE THAT DIDN’T HAVE
SYMPTOMS THAT ASYMPTOMATIC THAT
DIDN’T GET TESTED.
PEOPLE THAT MIGHT HAVE
ANTIBODIES AND T-CELL IMMUNITY.
THAT’S A SIGNIFICANT NUMBER AS
WELL.
IT’S ALL GOING TOWARDS SLOWING
IT DOWN.
>> Dana: TO YOUR POINT IT IS
HARD TO MEASURE THAT BUT IT
LOOKS LIKE THINGS ARE HEADED IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE CHARTS.
BILL FOLLOWS "THE NEW YORK
TIMES" AND THE BAR CHART KEEPS
GOING DOWN AND WE HAVE A HUGE